well that's a good thing alex rodriguez
had a sweet reunion
while getting a workout in on saturday
a-rod spent some time with ex-wife
cynthia scurtis
who's the mother of their two children
natasha and ella
i think they love fitness their mother
cyndia is in great shape she's always
working out
in the video the former yankee shared to
his instagram story he called his ex
a quote world-class mommy and here they
are again
alongside a friend and another instagram
post from that day
it's a good time for us and it's great
to be supportive and loving to each
other and the gym day follows one month
after we learned that a-rod was looking
to shed his quote
dad bod following his split with
jennifer lopez in april
a source told e.t last month that he
quote 100
kicked into high gear over the last few
months he knows how good he looks when
all dressed up with somewhere to go now
the former couple frequently shared
snapshots of their joint workouts
but as they begin spending more time
apart the source added that a-rod
found himself not hitting the gym on the
regular i get to see
how gorgeous she is in the inside and
the outside it also learned that if
a-rod had it his way
him and j-lo would still be together the
source told us quote
it was definitely her call to end it and
he would have loved for it to keep going
following the split in april now j.lo
and ex-fiance ben affleck have rekindled
their past romance
over 15 years after they broke up and
parted on good terms
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
and another source told e.t that a-rod
is quote shocked
by her quick rebound the source added
quote
at the end of the day alex wants
jennifer to be happy
but the way everything has unfolded
doesn't sit well with him
but we do know that in the aftermath of
relationships coming to an end
a-rod has always prioritized his family
my number one focus is my daughter's
that's what i think about 24-7 a-rod and
cynthia were married for six years
before going their separate ways
in 2008 and after their split he told us
how important it was for them to support
each other
while raising their two daughters i
write these little love notes
so every time when i get home from
yankee stadium i get home and i say
you know we won last night daddy went
one for four
he drove in two runs daddy's right
hamstring hurts a little bit
i hope you girls enjoy your day at
school i can't wait to talk to you after
school
and and cynthia just reads them these
notes as they do as she drives them to
school and it's just kind of been our
thing and
it's just been really exciting i mean i
i miss them tremendously
it's amazing that you have found that
great balance and how hard did you have
to work to find that balance to
with your ex and their girls i've been
fortunate because um you know cynthia
and i are best of friends
to this day we still go on vacations
together and
it is all about our daughters and you
know i've known now cynthia almost
17 years and we're still best of friends
and we we co-parent our kids and i think
we do a very good job of that
but that is 100 both of our priorities
and
the kids for for me are the big winners